yo boo lay cat podcast man special guest
in here my guy compton
now listen before we have you do what
you do man uh you just dropped a new
song today that's crazy yeah yeah yeah
shout outs to um you know we dropping
the whole uh yellow hill
myself haiti baby going crazy called
jumping yeah yeah that song is crazy
thank you thank you brother um i you
know what's crazy about you is you
always i was telling you this earlier
you just like have a
niche for just putting out just bangers
bro like i feel like two times a year
like we could count on a compton av
just record that's just like okay this
is one of them ones that's gonna go up
good looking yeah just just trying to
keep it um
fresh clean i know i know you've been
doing singles and [ __ ] are you is there
a project coming yeah i got a project
coming titled net 30.
yeah you're the first platform i told
like the name of the uh project gonna be
so yeah you were just playing me some
[ __ ] too that's special man hey man yeah
you had i mean you played four or five
songs straight that were just crazy yeah
you got some big [ __ ] on the way man and
let's just get to it you brought you
brought a beat too so we're just going
to get right do it man it's the intro
i'm the missing piece to the youth
but to the streets i'm the truth
and to the ops i'm a trophy boy said the
hood i get on beats and let my soul
speak
this ain't a song that's an anthem wanna
see my [ __ ] all get rich and ride
phantoms cash out mansions and bust down
rollies running up a check instead of
running from the police [ __ ] i ain't no
nothing about no richard millie i was
trying not to slip and let these [ __ ]
kill me cause these [ __ ] doing drills
for the thrill everything i rap is real
hey this [ __ ] to get you chills it's a
call world but i'm still outside [ __ ]
praying on my downfall but still i rise
and when i die blow a whole bag at my
funeral all white doves my [ __ ] better
be beautiful
the city better celebrate my legacy and
make sure them [ __ ] as my brothers
when they carry me tell all of my ex
hoes don't show up and embarrass me and
put a million dollars in my casket when
they bury me this therapy that's what my
music like for street [ __ ] we took all
losses like bosses we gon keep winning
[ __ ] ghosted on the net [ __ ] sneak
dissing but tell our opps we 50 up and
we gon keep spinning hunny round draco
we get busy no kissing you looking at
that [ __ ] in the city we get litty them
suckers switch sides now them [ __ ] on
my [ __ ] list i'm looking in the mirror
can't believe i made it this rich bust
down cardi on my wrist this [ __ ] feel
different [ __ ] praying that i lose but
i'm still winning a [ __ ] made it out
the trenches but i'm still in it you
inside we outside in the field with it
first check i went crazy in the streets
flooded out the cuban and went crazy on
the piece my second check the [ __ ]
going crazy with the chops i threw him
to the hood we going crazy on the ops i
be back chasing all this money on my
lonely i tell her like back back [ __ ]
you don't know me these groupie hoes
won't let me go she trying to hold me
remember back then she didn't want me
now she all on me the money didn't
change me it just changed the way i look
at [ __ ] man these [ __ ] don't really
love me they just full of [ __ ] cause you
were supposed to hold me up that's how i
should have went but [ __ ] let me down
now i'm careful who i pull up with i
didn't sing record deals and said i
wouldn't take it and took care of some
hoe [ __ ] that said i wouldn't make it
now these [ __ ] calling my phone trying
to rekindle this lamborghini only fit
two it's not a limo you [ __ ] not
invited to the party this time i'm
balling and i got another million on my
mind [ __ ] breaking alarm clocks they
should have said early i show them with
the true definition of net 30.
[ __ ]
new album that 30 coming soon man what's
it dropping what's it dropping one take
by the way one take by the way but yeah
drop it real soon just look for it
february march hey that's how we kick
off 2022 man that was crazy man captain
av go follow him on uh on and go go
stream all the music man hey man go
check out my new single i did it
featuring ot genesis and he's
independent doing it big rich off ramp
is the label boom y'all see that man oh
we see it man
we see it yeah all right busty bussy
town small boycott we're in the building
yeah